nouvelle rupture entre laure manaudou et
son entraîneur cette fois c'est le club
italien qui l'avait accueillie en mai
après son départ au tonitruant du cani
qui a décidé de l'exclure
l'entraîneur est à lire juge que son
attitude lors de l'open de paris n'est
pas acceptable
l'explication julien avaient des taux
avec frédéric bazille l'idylle aura duré
trois mois
ce soir laure manaudou n'a plus
d'entraîneur la sportive préférée des
français est exclu du club de turin pour
son entraîneur c'est la championne
olympique du caprice elle goûte
modérément la préparation sauce
italienne
le clash était inévitable entre paulo
bento et l ça n'a jamais été la dolce
vita
on l'a bien vu ce week end à l'open de
paris la championne a proprement ignorée
son entraîneur italien lui préférant
souvent la compagnie de son téléphone
portable
échauffement écourtée massage ap la
nageuse reconnaît son manque
d'investissement
je me suis pas fait ma cg pas tout fait
pour un montant non plus nos coeurs a
lancé c'est normal
peut-être parce que nous frapper si mal
au genou et l ingérable pas facile
d'entraîner l'or au quotidien philippe
lucas l'a appris à ses dépens congédié
par la championne il ya trois mois après
l'avoir conduit au titre olympique et
mondial
et quand elle part à turin pour se
rapprocher de son fiancé
l'expérience tourne au fiasco
normal un an des jeux olympiques de
pékin
laure manaudou se retrouve sans
entraîneur sans structure inquiétant
pour les dirigeants de la natation
française
là on est au bord du gouffre c'est à
dire que début septembre il faut qu'elle
soit une structure en tout cas qu'elles
en fassent le choix si elle fait ce pas
ce choix
je pense que il faut pas se voiler la
face on va à la catastrophe pour les
jeunes la fédération est d'ores et déjà
en mesure de lui fournir une liste de
cinq entraîneurs à laure manaudou de
faire son choix
mais ce sera dans trois semaines après
ses vacances